what's the best way to learn programming
what programming language should you
learn first is ai going to replace
developers in this video you will hear
answers to 10 of the most common
questions that people new to software
development have
this collaboration video features
answers from a bunch of experienced
software developers and tutorial
creators will ai ever replace developers
wow people really like this question i
answered this question a lot i don't
think so no i don't think so no i don't
think so well i don't think so hard no
the answer is no i'm not seeing this
like a problem not really and the short
answer is no i do not think that ai will
replace developers anytime soon i do
however think that it will get rid of
all the boring repetitive tasks that we
don't want to do and allow us to focus
on the problem solving and creating
aspects that software development can
bring
actually ai is our friend as developers
because it's creating lots of helpful
tools
that reduce the amount of work we have
to do and the amount of typing we have
to do
to
create new things and write code as
developers
i think it will enhance us as developers
it will save us from doing these
repetitive tasks something like an
engine on the boat that helps it to go
faster in my opinion i think ai
is a great addition of the set of tools
that we already have and it will allow
us to be more efficient
faster
and
really speed up the development life
cycle
with auto completions that we've seen
with some of the tools that already are
out there
um ai is only as good as the data that
we put into it if you dig a little bit
deeper into what ai exactly is it's just
a data set that is used for predictions
now in the case of github copilot for
example the predictions are really
really good it seems to know what i want
to type so that is perfect but i don't
think it will ever actually replace
developers because you know we can still
have a lot of creativity that systems
won't have and consider this there are
still developers needed to create the ai
what i think all i see happening is ai
coming into the tech field to help aid
developers productivity
or help automate some of the tasks that
developers have to do for your
day-to-day i believe that ai will not be
an independent power tool that will just
magically do everything that developers
do now but rather it will be just one of
the tools for developers themselves to
actually make their own work more
efficient and delegate some of their
tasks ai will help optimize developers
work but certainly not replace them i
use google copilot all the time and i'm
not really worried about it but if i
were the kind of person that would
occasionally get things very spookily
right and then sometimes create stuff
that's just wildly out of nowhere
i might be replaced by copilot
all the traditional jobs we know and
love today will eventually be replaced
by ai i'm a big believer in the
singularity and that eventually
artificial intelligence will surpass
human intelligence they're always going
to need us to develop simple
applications complex applications help
even develop the ai
that helps developers such as copilot
work the way it does ai will not replace
developers because there will always be
jobs for programmers to work on small
scale medium or large projects
ai will not be able to do that all on
its own it can certainly be useful and
can assist in development processes but
it will not do the whole thing on its
own unless of course ai becomes
self-aware at which point we'll have
bigger things to worry about than our
jobs i think that someone will always
need to maintain something right there's
infrastructure to be maintained there's
always going to be some code to write
someone needs to write code to make the
ai work in general i think that ai even
if it were to replace the typical jobs
that we do today it just means that
engineers will have to adapt to
something different but i don't think
it's going to replace them completely
what is the best way to learn
programming through courses or by
yourself
when you're just beginning you need some
kind of a guideline or a roadmap because
you don't know what you need to learn in
which order you need to learn or
generally you have no idea where to
start
so on a beginner level i recommend
starting with courses and then
go ahead and practice with actual real
life projects i think you will spend
as a developer most time of your life
learning programming so the learning
does not really stop
so if you find
courses beneficial then go in for
courses but i'll tell you now the
ability to study on your own is the
one of the most valued abilities of the
developer
honestly i'm a big fan of courses
because they provide structure and i
think having structure is very important
when you're learning something and you
don't know where to go
if you are simply
learning a new language you're already
proficient in several languages then i
think the best way is to go by yourself
and just read the docs and build
projects but if you're starting from
scratch i think
coding
courses and then also simultaneously
working on projects is the best way to
go in my opinion courses will allow you
to at least get the foundational
understanding then you need to go by
yourself and start creating
products
applications websites etc using the
skills that you've just learned
i think taking a course is still
technically by yourself but more
structured when you go through a course
you're going to learn new things but
then it's up to you to take that
knowledge and apply it to your needs go
build something on your own after the
course
well i would say it's a mixture of
things i would advise all my students
always watch the tutorial first however
not just rely on the tutorial too much i
would recommend completely getting rid
of what you've just built with the
tutorial and just starting from scratch
really seeing if you can do it all by
yourself and really seeing if you can
make the project your own
the best way to learn programming is
really what works for you do you learn
best by digging in a book going through
a course or even a combination of the
two
but ultimately one thing that will help
everyone is to practice by creating
projects i had a math professor that
wants a math is not a spectator sports
and the same goes with programming you
need to get the practice in to get
better
in my opinion i think through courses
because you can find someone that you
fully understand and you feel
comfortable
like listening through the examples
because some concepts can be really
really difficult to grasp if you just
for example reading books or through
blogs whereas if someone is teaching you
and then explaining along the way
through for example videos which i think
is one of the best ways of learning
programming i think that will take you a
long way as you start off
then once you are comfortable and
understand for example the programming
language or the framework this is when i
feel like by yourself is better because
you can challenge yourself through
whatever project
that you think will basically allow you
to
learn all the skills that you've learned
from someone else it's more like you if
you're just getting started you need to
go ahead and take some fundamental
courses about programming maybe you
learn web development javascript you get
the first steps you learn the basics
then afterward you can jump on your own
project and install learning by yourself
and this way you will be able to like
explore and read more documentation like
how to solve problems by yourself like
explore more libraries start your own
portfolio and much much more personally
i would say both because
being self-taught developer myself i
relied a lot on online resources like
courses to help me learn some of the
technologies that i was learning so
you can do it yourself but to be honest
you still need to rely or look out for
resources online to help the answer to
this really varies by two factors
by your individual preference
and also by the situation that you're in
for some people
it's better to go the self-learning
route and some people need the
motivation
and
the
personal involvement and structure that
something like a coding school or a boot
camp brings
there's no one path to get into coding
what if everyone became a programmer
well realistically i don't think that
will happen but i definitely do think
that it will help if everyone has some
basic understanding of how code works
how computer works because that will
help for security we will get a more
diverse set of people in programming so
that will definitely help as well to
break some paradigms and
get some creative new things out there
which will be really great so i do
definitely think that everyone should
have some basic knowledge of programming
but will everyone become a programmer i
hope not
first off not everyone is going to want
to be a programmer
people have different interests and
there's room for everybody's
interests and passions in the world
that being said i do think that at least
in school everyone should learn
the basics of programming i agree with
steve jobs here when he says everyone
should learn how to code because it
teaches you how to think
i think that
logic
like stepping through problems
and all those related skills that kind
of fit under
the umbrella of learning to code
are really valuable
regardless of what career you go into
also coding skills can be very helpful
even in non-coding jobs
i've heard a lot of people who have used
a little bit of python or a little bit
of visual basic to automate some of
their tasks at work and really help them
out with other things or maybe someone
will learn to code and then just use it
for side projects or
building things that they really want to
exist for themselves or for the rest of
the world
and coding
creates an opportunity for people to be
able to do that
that's the beauty of learning to code
you can take it anywhere and do so many
things with it outside of just working
as a developer i don't think that is
possible mainly because coding and
programming is not for everybody some
may like it some may not like it that
being said though if for whatever reason
everybody decided to become a programmer
that simply means that the demand on the
job market is very high for programmers
which is good for everybody this is
really not worth worrying about i think
if the concern is
what if there's too many people in the
job pool and everyone's trying to get
into the same jobs
i think that's already happening today
but if you take a look at the software
engineers salaries they're still very
high and that's because even with all of
the supply it's still very hard to find
talent so as long as i think if you
strive to be a good engineer it really
is not a problem for you to think about
well i think it's more of a self-feeding
cycle the more programmers we have the
more awesome technologies and generally
technological progress we have which
means we again need more developers for
those new technologies
however i do think that the simple
coding and programming skills will not
be enough for a professional software
developer so while some years ago just
average javascript knowledge was a
superpower now as a developer you
actually need to bring much more skills
to compete with other developers because
again the programming field is rapidly
growing and becoming more and more
competitive
that's never going to happen i'm not
really worried about it though but it
would mean a worldwide shortage on hot
pockets
that would be cool but it's not going to
happen don't worry about there being too
many programmers the demand for talented
programmers goes up every year as
technologies advance there are tons of
open rules everywhere i'm 30 40 or 50 is
it too old to learn how to program
no
no definitely not it's never too late to
start it doesn't matter the age
absolutely not i don't think it is ever
too late to learn anything absolutely
yes turns out that a
switch flips in your brain when you're
30 years old and you're unable to
process new information which is why i
don't know how game of thrones ended but
i'm sure it ended well
well i don't think so i think
programming can be learned at any stage
in your life
programming is a skill it doesn't really
matter how old you are like literally
you just have to be consistent you can
literally learn to code at any point in
your life you can learn programming at
any age i know people that you know from
their 30s 40s they decided that they had
enough from what they were doing and
they just became a programmer so it's
completely up to you whether you have
the right mindset
literally anyone it doesn't matter the
age anyone can learn how to code age
doesn't mean anything at all i don't
think it is ever too late to learn
anything basically as long as you kind
of enjoy it you know maybe a job can be
harder at a certain age because of all
kinds of prejudice that is out there by
companies which is you know not great
but it's unfortunately the reality but
i feel if you want to learn anything the
time is now
a lot of things you need to get started
with learning how to code honestly is
out there for free in the internet and
there's a an abundance of
information that you can just grab
whenever so i truly believe whatever
limitation it is that you think you have
it's probably not your age it really is
just your own self belief of can you do
it or can you not do it my
recommendation would be to just get
started learn a little bit each day and
just see where that goes i'm currently
teaching my mom to do some html css on
javascript so i never think uh never say
never always is a good time to start
learning anything really not just
software development if it's either for
a career switch into a developer job or
just as a hobby programming can be for
anyone of any age
absolutely not i i think age
even though obviously it is a real thing
it's also a social construct all of
these expectations around
what time you should be doing things at
what age should you be
doing any particular task those are all
just social constructs so i don't think
you should believe
anybody that tells you you can't do
something no matter what age you are yes
it will be harder to learn because when
you're younger your brain is like a
sponge and it retains information better
but regardless of your age you can 100
learn to code and you should if that's
something you're passionate about i
actually personally know a lot of people
over 40 that started learning to code
and now are getting careers out of it
like complete career switches so now i
don't think
you can ever be too old
is a diploma in computer science worth
it
worth it probably but required probably
not but then again this kind of depends
on what field of programming you're
going after some may require formal
education some may not it also depends
on the location where you live and so on
so i would say if you are able to afford
a formal education go for it then it
will be worth it but if you can't please
don't take out any loans because it's
not going to be worth it in that case
that really depends on your situation
if you have the money and time to
invest in a computer science degree and
it's also the best option for you
personally
and mentally then i would say yes a
computer science degree
would be great
it gives you lots of access to
professors who are knowledgeable about
the foundations of computer science
you're going to get really great
foundational
knowledge of software engineering
you'll also have access to lots of
resources you'll be able to network with
people in the industry maybe get
internships that's a really good leg up
into
a career as a software developer many
jobs will even say they require a degree
in computer science
or
that equivalent amount of experience on
the job
web development in general can
definitely be done without a degree
especially with all the free ways of
learning that are out there now it's
actually quite easy to get started with
programming without going for a degree
well in my opinion the answer has been
no
i have a diploma that i got after i
already learned to code and i've never
used it but if you can afford to go to
college and have that experience i think
it's good that people get a diploma so
that they can have that experience of
learning how to learn in a real college
scenario do i think it makes you a
better developer
no
i have mixed feelings about this because
it really depends on what career you
want to pursue personally i don't think
my computer science degree was worth it
because i could have learned
actually i did learn
most of my knowledge from youtube
from online courses from
free resources from google and stack
overflow that's where i gained most of
my knowledge but what university was
very useful for is
building a network of people
uh providing you with opportunities
and having a structured approach to
learning so it's useful for those three
things but it is definitely not
necessary so if that's what's holding
you back from entering the tech world
then
don't get one just learn by yourself
maybe take a boot camp but you can 100
learn on your own and don't let a
computer science degree or feeling like
you need one hold you back i don't have
one
but i think it's fine i think if you do
get into this and you go through a boot
camp and they don't teach you data
structures and algorithms it is probably
something that you want to follow up on
and if you want to get into something
like machine learning then some extra
math would also do well but
yeah i don't think it's necessary for a
practical working job at this point well
i personally don't have a computer
science degree software development or
computer science wasn't really something
on my radar i actually studied
architecture so i did the maths i did
the physics and it just wasn't really a
thing i'd run my um friendship group
so if i didn't do it you don't have to
of course it does help but it's not a
really hard prerequisite
absolutely if you have time and money to
go to the university go for it because
apart from the knowledge most
importantly you're going to meet the
right people i don't think it's worth it
at all
but if you of course if you have a
diploma it's a great add-on you can add
it to your cv and it's just like a great
item for you but for just being getting
a developer you don't need a diploma you
can learn all by yourself my short
answer to that is no the longer answer
is it feels specifically has a big
advantage that whatever there is to
learn you can actually learn yourself
from online courses youtube videos self
practice etc you can even create a
portfolio of your projects host them
into a git repository and show it to
your potential employers as an evidence
of your knowledge plus i would argue
that most of the latest technologies or
latest versions of the established
technologies aren't always taught at
universities simply because they can
update their curriculum so fast to keep
up with these changes
i would say it is i think that if you
have one it might be a little bit easier
to break into the industry although it
does take a lot of time and money so
those are your main considerations if
you don't have a lot of either of those
then perhaps a boot camp might also work
for you so was it worth it i think it
was for me
is it required though no there's
different avenues nowadays to
break into the industry you don't need a
diploma to get started i would say
if you have the money then absolutely
yes it is worth it because computer
science will teach you things that
uh will help you to become a better
programmer in the long run however if
you don't have the money then i think
that you should maybe just try a boot
camp or for example here in the uk the
government is giving free
12-week program for people to get into
coding which is amazing how programming
influences your health
it's a very sedentary job you're sitting
in front of a computer for many hours
every single day
and from a physical perspective that can
really take a toll on you
i have implemented quite a few systems
to help keep me active throughout the
day
i set
reminders on my watch so my watch will
vibrate every hour or so and let me know
that i need to stand up and walk around
for at least one minute it's very easy
to get caught up in a problem or writing
code and all of a sudden eight hours
goes by and you haven't eaten you
haven't had any water or gotten up to do
some exercise so be sure to take routine
breaks and
i really love my standing desk it keeps
me from sitting all day i do think that
with any sort of job when you sit too
long at computer it is important to get
up stretch your legs get away from the
computer every 20 minutes or so even
though that does seem quite hard now
when i think about it i definitely don't
do that enough but i would say that
taking short breaks letting your eyes
rest is key when uh doing what we do
it's very addictive so i remember when i
started
as a junior developer i just wanted to
you know
fix a bug from friday i would spend
saturday and sunday working on it and
then monday and then carry on for you
know weeks and weeks just focusing on
programming without no break and
obviously that can have a big impact in
your life so
burnout is a common thing within
programmers
yes programming can have an effect in
your health but i would say it's like
everything right so you know just don't
have too much of it and it won't be a
problem well it definitely makes your
brain more active and possibly saves you
from alzheimer's but because you sit
down a lot you need to plan in a lot of
physical activity in order to stay slim
not great it is a lot of sitting down
and that's not particularly awesome for
your health but
i have noticed that i do apply kind of
an engineering rigor to my workouts and
when i actually work out that actually
helps a lot so there is that it's kind
of a funny question but i think there's
some truth to it because if you really
get caught up in a problem with
programming then it's easy to maybe
drink too much coffee do not get up
enough from your chair maybe eat some
unhealthy food because it's just easy
and you want to focus on the problem so
make sure to get up exercise eat healthy
do all kinds of things but also for your
mental state right it's very much a
profession where you have to think a lot
so make sure to disconnect at times do
something completely different to relax
and not get too caught up in complex
problems that won't let you go
well for me it's quite an advantage
because i am remote and i get to work my
own hours i get to go to the gym five
times a week if not seven and i get to
powerlift every single day
so for me i get to enjoy what i love at
the gym
and also get to program
mentally i use the gym to give me
clarity as well as taking away any
stress
i might have from the job that i do
so a lot of times as developers we are
literally on our desks sitting for hours
upon hours and in the long run this
could cause
back aches or you can start having eye
problems so in this scenario what i
would advise is as developers we should
take care of ourself if you notice that
you're having back ache you should
definitely get yourself an economic
chair that would help you balance
properly or a stunning decks where you
can switch between sitting and standing
and also if you are having eye problems
because you're always looking at the
screen definitely get yourself a blue
light blocking glass this really helps
improve your eyesight as you work every
day do you need to know meth to become a
developer seriously no absolutely not i
don't know where this comes from i
actually teach programming in elementary
schools to fourth graders and they have
this idea that takes a lot of math so
it's got to be like an episode of
sesame street or something please don't
watch that episode
now doing maths well it's very helpful
is not again a hard prerequisite for
learning how to code there are many
avenues that don't require any maths at
all for example when i was working as a
software developer in my old company the
amount of maths i did was very
negligible when creating games for my
tutorials it is a bit higher but it just
depends what kind of area you go into
this depends again on what you wanted to
do as a programmer for instance if you
want to be a game developer you may need
to know some math especially if you're
working on game engine that will involve
a lot of game physics
but in general no you wouldn't really
need any math to become a developer
no myself i wasn't that good with maths
but still i'm a software engineer
obviously depending whether you want to
you know go into a role where it's you
know heavily maths focused such as a
quant developer then yes you need to
know maps but there are many areas in
software engineering that you don't need
to know maths at all right so also it
depends on on the industry that you
you're planning to go into but in
general you don't need maps
well it depends on the type of developer
if you're going to be doing machine
learning or data analytics or quantum
computing then yeah but in general you
just need to know basic math
math is obviously a related field right
in in programming you're likely going to
be working with some form of numbers you
know you might be writing some
algorithms but does that mean that you
need to be a math expert not necessarily
i think you know if you do a typical cs
degree you'll have you'll learn a little
bit of math but it doesn't necessarily
turn you into a mathematician or
anything like that right so do you need
to know some math yeah i think so but do
you need to be like an expert
mathematician no not really
well i don't think so like
literally you can be a developer without
knowing maths because at the end of the
day depending on the kind of developer
you are you don't have to
deal with mathematics so for for example
if you're a front-end developer you
might need it at some point for example
if you're doing like css calc you need
to know like a bit of calculation table
to be honest it's not a deal breaker for
you to become a developer so maths
is a good knowledge to have but not
required absolutely not you don't need
math skills to become a developer i
would argue that if you know fourth
grade math that will be more than enough
to start learning programming
what you need though is a decent amount
of logical thinking skill which you can
easily develop with practice because
programming is about being creative and
making logical connections and finding
solutions
so programming doesn't follow any
predefined mathematical formulas
so if the fact that you're not good at
math is what's holding you back then you
have nothing to fear about because
that's not going to be a roadblock for
you
how long does it take to become a junior
deaf now the natural progression of a
developer is very different depending on
where you are mine was to do a boot camp
then a graduate scheme and then become a
junior developer and all in all i think
that process including the bootcamp took
about a year so that is just something
that i went through but again it's
different for everyone
well as computer science evolves you
probably need to know a lot more today
than you would um have
required to know in like say 90s
but
i think six months is a safe period
considering
that you will be
say practicing
at least once a day
i guess for somebody who's gonna learn
on a daily basis it would be from like
four to six months to be a decent junior
dev but for others who just like learn
from time to time i guess most of them
is going to be like 10 to 12 months to
be a good junior dev there is no set
amount of time that anyone can promise
you where you will be a junior developer
in so many months
now i think it's really helpful
to get inspiration from people's stories
where they say oh i became a developer
in three months or six months and this
is how i did it
but that doesn't mean that it will be
the same for you
it could take you two years and that's
okay that's your own path
also everyone comes into software
development
with a different background
i started coding html probably when i
was 11 or 12 years old
some people have almost never used a
computer or can barely use email
and some people have already built lots
of things in programming languages
so you can never compare yourself to
other people it depends on how much
effort you put into learning depending
on your current circumstances you may or
may not be able to invest the same
amount of time as others in general i'd
say 6 to 12 months but don't compare
yourself to others go at your own pace
and don't rush you're going to be a
better developer if you take the time to
really learn the fundamentals i could
tell you that it would take you three
months to become a junior dev but i
might be wrong or i might be right it's
really individual because everybody
learns at different uh pace and
everybody learns different ways
so uh while it could take you three
months you could take somebody else nine
months or even more so don't be
discouraged if it takes you a little bit
longer to become a junior dev than
somebody else don't compare yourself to
somebody else
it's okay and there is nothing wrong
with uh taking a little bit longer
take your time and just do what you're
doing it will take you exactly as long
as it's needed for you personally to
become a junior dev
i think it really depends
uh online you do see a lot of the best
case scenarios so you know you see
people that learn to code and in six
months without a computer science degree
or anything they get a job at google or
you do see a lot of people that learn to
code and then get a six figure salary
three months later
i think those are best case scenarios
and even though that can happen and
absolutely yes it does happen it's not
the norm and it's not what you should
expect and i think it it discourages a
lot of people because they have those
high expectations but i think a
realistic expectation for learning to
code
from the day one to becoming a junior
dev and landing your first job would be
a year or even more i think
building those foundational skills
would take at least six months i
wouldn't trust anyone that tells you it
can take less i think we should set a
little bit more realistic timelines
which programming language to choose
first now this is of course a great
question and again it depends on where
you are geographically or what you're
interested in for me i did html css
javascript and then moved on to react
and started looking at some python and
some back-end development as well but
again that is not a hard
you must do this it will be different
for everyone out there well i don't
think there is one right answer to this
i think that is the language that you
enjoy most the one that sticks with you
so try out a couple of different
languages and see whichever one works
for you i also feel that if you've
mastered the wonderful art of
programming that it doesn't really
matter what language you use if you
fully understand one language you can
apply those concepts to any language out
there i would go with javascript just
because you know you can use it for
front end you can use it for backend you
know basically you can do it for full
stack you can use it for mobile
development so you really you can go all
over the place with javascript and it's
a multi-paradigm language so there's a
lot that you can learn about programming
with just that one language so i think
if you're not sure in my opinion
nowadays javascript is an absolutely
great way to get started 100 what i
would recommend is python python was my
first programming language and what we
learned in university and that is
because it reads like english it has
very simple syntax it's easy to learn
it's easy to understand as a beginner
and it can help teach you the
foundations if you do want to do
front-end then i would recommend
javascript and obviously learning html
and css in my opinion i think you should
pick a language that will teach you
uh the fundamentals of programming well
enough and as many concepts such as
object oriented programming interfaces
types for example right now if you go
into a language that doesn't teach you
all of these concepts then you can find
a little bit difficult to move forward
so the benefit of learning for example
language such as c plus plus java c
sharp c is that whatever other language
follows you'll see so many similarities
that you'll see that language is just a
tool for you to solve a problem
now i'm a c-sharp developer i love the
language and i do think it's a great one
to get started with but ultimately i
would probably choose python mostly for
there being so much learning material
for it and it can be easy to get started
with
c sharp is a very close second then
if i were starting out i would go to the
local job market and see what's on
demand and go from there another way is
to simply try out multiple different
languages and see which one you would
like which is easier maybe you like the
syntax of one language better than the
other and so on
people fall into a few different
categories when they're learning to
program
some people already have a goal in mind
of what they want to do for example you
want to become a mobile app developer
while then you will learn
java and or swift
to work in that ecosystem
now if you don't know what you want to
do
there are two recommendations
that i have from working with students
over the years
and the first
is that
if you really
have
no background
in programming or much technology at all
or if you are an artist or very design
oriented
i recommend learning html css and
javascript first
one great thing about that stack is it
starts you off with the most
basic
languages like html css and gives you
instant feedback in the browser
for everything that you're building and
the changes you're making
the nice thing about that stack is a
browser is something almost everyone is
already used to using so it gives you
kind of that comfortable place to start
coding
if you are a little bit more tech savvy
and or you are not
very good with design my recommendation
is to learn python first it is such a
great general purpose programming
language has a wonderful community and
is used in pretty much every different
type of programming from scripting to
web development blockchain ai all
different sorts of things this is kind
of a complex question and i'm going to
preface it with it doesn't really matter
but if you're a front end dev or you
want to be a front-end dev choose html
css and javascript
get the basics down and move on if
you're a back-end dev choose a back-end
technology that excites you such as java
go python for example
other than that it's just about picking
something and getting started
i mostly recommend to start with
javascript because it's easy it's
flexible and it's the most popular
programming language for developing web
applications
because programming is generally pretty
abstract so starting with web
applications where you can see the
results visually in the browser helps a
lot to understand what you're actually
programming because you have some actual
visual feedback
plus javascript can be used for both
front-end and back-end development so
with one language you actually learn the
basis of the full-stack web development
for me i started with c and c plus plus
but i guess for nowadays it would be
better to start with something like
javascript or maybe python but i see
javascript is a better choice to go for
since it runs literally everywhere give
us some tips on motivating yourself to
study i would say start with the project
it will be something fun to work on
instead of doing random exercises or
going
straight through a book or a course
and with the project you'll more likely
get to go oh i need to do this for it to
do what i wanted to do and you'll go and
see how to do it and you'll learn how to
do it at the same time
i can share two tips here the first tip
is
for you to create
a study time table
by having a study time table you've
already set aside time for when you
would like to study this really helps
you because then there is no
way you would say that for example you
don't have the time or something else is
blocking your time because now you have
a schedule the other thing i'll say is
for you to find a study group a study
group really helps motivate you because
do you you have a group of other people
that you can look out to
that would help motivate you to go ahead
and study so having a study group is
great and also setting a study time
table is also a great way to be
motivated i guess the best way would be
to find what interests you the most and
try to learn it
also i find it a good way is actually to
follow video tutorials and try to like
follow them and create whatever projects
because this is going to give you a lot
of more motivation and a push forward to
learn by yourself and create your own
projects start sharing your progress
with the developer community it could be
on social media like on twitter for
example or discord or somewhere else
just make sure that you're sharing your
progress it will give you the needed
motivation there are
many different kinds of motivation that
work for different people but one of the
best things for me personally is to
follow inspirational people on social
media i love getting inspired by
different accounts
also to force myself to study i
typically use the two-minute rule which
is just telling yourself that you're
going to do something for two minutes
and after two minutes you can stop but
usually because you gain momentum you
don't stop after two minutes so you kind
of trick yourself into
spending the time to do that certain
activity obviously that's not
only for programming it's for everything
but i find the two-minute rule always
helps me
and you know time blocking every single
night i'm going to learn to code from
this time to this time and sticking to
that is super important
i would say
being part of a community it's really
really important because you'll find
like-minded people like yourself
and you'll feel like you're not alone in
this journey if you are part of the
community
get engaged
ask questions um have study groups with
people meet people
and that way will drive you forward
every single day there are days that
you'll feel like oh this is so difficult
and if you're alone it's much easier for
you to give up
now
if you are within community and you've
got people supporting you then you kind
of feel you know someone uplifting you
all the way if you are stuck you ask
questions
and yeah just uh be part of the
community i think it's one of the best
things that you should do to motivate
yourself well motivation is a short-term
boost you need to have a clear
understanding why you're doing this
this is how
you'll make sure that you'll go through
all the rainy days
and all the days where you don't really
want to
study at all and generally
try to switch between activities
let's say you're coding then switching
to something like running or
lifting weights this is how you can
split your d and not to get bored with
what you do this is kind of a difficult
question for me because i'm a
self-motivated
learner who wants to learn about
everything regardless if it's tech
cars nature woodworking whatever i'm
super interested in learning all the
time
so i motivate myself by finding
something i'm interested in and then i
start reading about it and decide
whether or not it can hold my interest
for a long time once i have that i can
study all day every day about a topic
i think the most fun way to learn
anything is with actual real projects
that are interesting for you so once you
learn the basics of a programming
language from a course for example you
can start practicing yourself for
example if you want to learn javascript
think about a web application you would
want to develop for yourself maybe you
love sports so you want to develop a web
application that shows all the fun
sports events and activities near you
whatever it is this will make it much
more fun to learn coding than just going
through a book or a course with boring
generic examples sure there will always
be cases where you have to force
yourself to do a little bit but i think
if you can find something that you enjoy
most something that feels like a hobby
then the motivation will be no problem
you will enjoy it so much that you will
continue working on it you will find any
spare time that you have to put into it
and the motivation will be no problem at
all so make sure to find something that
makes you happy
don't study
build stuff and study what you need as
you're building stuff to build the stuff
it's called constructivist learning and
it's a way of teaching yourself new
things by doing those things you don't
learn how to make cabinets by just
thinking about making cabinets you'll
make cabinets by building cabinets same
sort of thing with software you learn
how to build software by building
software
it was so helpful to me when i was
starting out to really consider why i
was getting into software development i
was at a complete dead end in my life
i'd wanted to do this for a long time
and i finally pushed myself
to become a professional developer back
in 2015.
one of the ways that i did that
was writing down
my reasons all of my whys
for getting into software development
where i could see them and remember them
and i found that very motivating for me
another thing that i have realized
that can really help you
push through challenges and when you get
stuck
is something i call building early and
often
you really need to have
successes along your journey while you
are learning to code
one of the best ways of measuring
success is by building projects
when you can look back and see the
history of things you have built
and see how they started from simple
little projects and got slowly more
advanced over time you can really feel
how much you have been growing and
learning so even when you're stuck on
something and you feel like i can't do
this or why can't i just get it
and you start to say all of these
negative things to yourself you can look
back and say wait i have come so far and
learned so much this is just a small
bump in the road and whether i figured
this out right now or later on it
doesn't matter i'm still going to
make it to my destination
always think of it this way study as if
your job depended on it which it does
right you know how much you study is
going to determine how well you'll be
able to break into the field the
industry and if you're already in the
industry how much you study or how much
you learn in general is going to
determine you know how fast you go from
a junior to a senior so as an engineer
you're going to be constantly studying
and learning try to do a little bit each
day if you're struggling you know use
pomodoro or something like that
join studying communities there's a lot
of them online go to coffee shops go to
libraries wherever it is that it
motivates you to study go there but in
general just try to do a little bit each
day and you know make a routine out of
it and that's really all you need is
just build a system that keeps pushing
you forward in programming there is
never an end to learning there's always
something new to learn about so don't
get overwhelmed take breaks from
studying or just reading about something
by building something with the
technology that you're studying about
you're going to learn so much faster and
it's going to make it more interesting
also study things that motivate you if
you're not interested in something then
it's going to make it so much harder to
learn about it now i think the most
important thing when you're studying is
to find something you are genuinely
interested in so for example if you are
currently learning javascript and you're
just not into making to-do lists there
are plenty of other things to build out
there if you want to build a game then
definitely find that or if you want to
build a website that is cool too